peace between armenia and azerbaijan
and the armenians are thrilled about it
[Applause]
wait why did an angry mob storm
armenia's parliament
what's really going on here
a peace agreement brokered by russia has
been reached between armenia and
azerbaijan to
end the war in nagorno-karabakh a
disputed region in the caucasus
the fighting left around 5 000 dead and
over 130
000 displaced armenians in azerbaijanis
russian military planes delivered troops
and vehicles
as peacekeepers in nagorno-karabakh so
unlike previous ceasefires in the past
weeks
this one should stick according to the
peace deal
whichever country's army controls a
certain territory now
that country gets to keep it and that
includes shusha
the second largest settlement in
nagorno-karabakh
the thing about shusha is its strategic
importance
whoever controls shusha pretty much
controls all of nagorno-karabakh
azerbaijan also gained land access to
its nakchivan exclave bordering iran in
turkey
and armenia agreed to surrender
territories surrounding nagorno-karabakh
to azerbaijan that's basically why the
armenians are so upset
nagorno-karabakh is populated mostly by
armenians
and it's now dominated by azerbaijan
which is backed by turkey
armenian communities in the region are
concerned about
this because there is a long history of
persecution of armenians
by foreign powers most notably when 1.5
million armenians were killed and
expelled by turkey
between 1914 and 1923 in what is known
as the armenian
genocide while many armenians are
protesting against what they see as
their defeat
and calling their government traitors
azerbaijanis
are celebrating the peace deal
[Music]
azerbaijan started this war and now it's
celebrating victory
but i don't think there are winners in
any war there are only
losers when you look at all the
casualties riding over peace
or celebrating land grabs is just wrong
but if armenia's anger over this deal
ends up toppling the government that
signed it azerbaijan might regret
rubbing this deal in armenia's face